I'm not a political artist in an overt
way I don't make statements and it's not
in your face but I see myself and I see
you're all painting is essentially
political in the sense that that
politics is a responsibility to deal
with history and the history of how do
you make your experience relevant and
how do you communicate that experience
to other beings other people younger
people I've always been really
fascinated with in the sense i call them
the trophies of production the in a way
it's almost like I'm interested in what
it all boils down to i was interested to
that and when i was 22 I've kept
journals you see things repeated over
and over i I've read obituaries since
I'm 19 years old every day and I do it
without a sense of morbidity I really do
it because to me it's almost like living
your life in Reverse you have to look at
the end and think about the life you
would have wanted to live and then do it
and that sense of mortality was uh I
don't know exactly why uh maybe he was
just the pessimism of growing up in a
post depression Jewish family will you
hear stories of everything from starving
to poverty to Holocaust who knows
but I have the I've always done it I
always look and I always see lives
that's with your bitch where he is a
life boil down and you know you can't
help judging you know a live boil down
to service a life boil down to being in
their community a life boil down to
contribution or is it a life boil down
to the golf club I mean obviously I
always knew witched which side of that I
wanted to be on and I was always very
aware and my work always even before age
I thought it's almost like I think it
was William Beckett said you know I
can't go on I must go on I'll go on I
always felt that I can't I must I will
you know it's almost like I read the
paper I look around you know the
situation and you have to get up in the
morning and you have to say to yourself
never the less these are the things that
I'm going to do and this is what I want
to bring into the world maybe slowly
maybe it takes time and over a period of
time hopefully there's that sense of
optimism and that sense of
responsibility and that sense of
joyfulness even if even if it comes
through a kind of sense of commemoration
and in melancholia which i think are the
two poles of everybody's work every
everybody's work